okay we're going to get started if
everyone can get seated
it's a it's a great pleasure to have my
former boss and current colleague Steve
Hyman here in the Stanley Center
translational neuroscience series
co-hosted with the poitras Center here
at the McGovern Institute I want to just
hit a few highlights from Steve CV
before I just talk a little bit about my
history with Steve Steve got his BA from
Yale went on to Harvard where he got his
MD and residency in psychiatry he then
actually became a bench scientist at
Harvard was studying through some of the
earliest studies on gene expression as
relationship the dopamine and learning
and an addiction and he was also head of
the Harvard Center for mind brain and
behavior and then he was tapped to be
the ni-mh intramural director uh where I
was the end and then I was appointed
scientific director under Steve and I'll
talk about that in a bit but after
shaking things up there for a few years
he was put in a witness protection
program the authorities moved him into a
job as Provost at Harvard where he
served also for a number of years and
and then moved to the Stanley Center
where he's our colleague today I when I
was at ni-mh it was clear Steve came in
to move the ni-mh into the modern age
and that was not just the intramural
program which probably needed it the
most but Steve was determined to move
not only intramural but the extramural
program and and amazingly even the
entire field of Psychiatry he was going
to try to move into the modern age and
while he was a tremendous believer in
behavior and the analysis of behavior he
wanted to feel to be grounded in
genetics molecular biology and the
role of genes and intracellular pathways
in shaping neural circuits that would
then lead to behavior with the ultimate
goal of helping people suffering from
mental illness and was not everyone
accepted that his philosophy and how the
field should be organized they did
deeply respect his commitment to helping
people with mental illness and I think
he did a he moved the needle
tremendously for both ni-mh and the
field into what is now the I think
modern modern neuroscience after going
to Harvard where he also shook things up
I think he would say I think it was
actually able to shake things up because
he was overshadowed by someone who who
was like the bad cub to see his good cop
and it's pushing the the Harvard Alston
initiative for example as many other
things but then but anyway were able to
recruit him to be head of the Stanley
Center where there was able to take over
from a tremendous foundation that had
been built up by EDD skullnick who
shared this philosophy of grounding the
field in genetics molecular biology but
then again seeing how the genes and gene
pathways influence cells and circuits
and behavior and steve is now champion
that effort even more and so we're
delighted to hear about his thoughts
today on the field the Stanley Center
and where he thinks neuroscience is
going Steve please
see Bob I thought you were going to talk
about some of our reviews of intramural
scientists together and the hard work
you had to do afterwards but that can be
for after a beer sometime with everybody
in the audience so it's great to be here
at this this is going to be somewhat
high level talk because a lot of people
the community keep asking you know what
is it that we're doing and I think it is
a great opportunity to not only share
what we're doing at the Stanley Center
but also hopefully to enlist no small
number of you in solving helping to
solve the very very hard problems that
we face just always pick an introductory
slide to remind us of the gravity of the
problem and this is an interesting slide
because what it shows is this measure of
years of healthy life lost to disability
and this is counts literally the world
health organization in the world bank
accounts these things so this is in
millions and this is age from you know
birth to 70 and what you can see is that
the the neuropsychiatric disorders are
the chronic disabling disorders of the
young so normally we think of chronic
illness we think of you know the late
stages of life we think of diabetes and
heart disease and other chronic hills
like that but but you know autism has
its onset in the first years of life and
is unremitting and ADHD one severe also
very early and disabling and
schizophrenia which we'll talk about
more on set late teens early 20s nuh
cruel sense just after families and
society have maximally invested in a
young person in terms of education and
development and people with
schizophrenia have a you know course of
some some modest remissions and relapses
but in general people are disabled for
the rest of their lives
and so on and so on it's also striking
that the this is a set of disorders that
in terms of disability seems to affect
females more than males even though you
know males have more autism or
schizophrenia but but females
cross-culturally have more of the really
common most common of the disabling
source which is which are mood disorders
may jure depression and some of the
anxiety disorders which in aggregate our
major depression is the leading source
of disability in this country and in
Europe with the single exception of
chronic low back pain that that does
cause more missed work than than
depression but anyway these are very
very severe problems but the issue is if
I'm going to be really reductive we and
we can ignore the benzodiazepines for a
second we really only have three drugs
we have lithium we have a whole family
of very similar antipsychotic drugs and
we have a whole family of very similar
antidepressant drugs now don't get me
wrong we wouldn't be without these these
have been miraculous clinically but the
prototype for the antipsychotic drugs
was identified this was chlorpromazine
in 1951 in a search actually for new
antihistamines turned out was an
antihistamine lots of other things too
but also blocked d 2 dopamine receptors
and though there's been a really very
useful second-generation antipsychotic
drugs the obligate target of all
antipsychotic drugs is still d to the
same the very same target or target of
the first prototype drug and for
antidepressants you know we have the
modern SSRIs and selective SNRIs and so
forth but again the molecular targets
remain generally the presynaptic
reuptake transporters and the mechanism
is increasing norepinephrine sort Onan
sometimes dopamine and synapses and the
other thing maybe shouldn't be such a
surprise but
efficacy with the soul still mysterious
exception of an anti-psychotic drug
clozapine which was also serendipitously
discovered in the early 1960s efficacy
stalled literally with the prototype
drug so the current antidepressants are
much safer they're more tolerable and
and this is not trivial when I was in
training in psychiatry we would be
terrified to prescribe antidepressants
because people could kill themselves
with a five-day supply and here they
were depressed and suicidal and today's
drugs are very safe very tolerable but
the efficacy is no greater and some
would say not quite as good as the very
first drug imipramine and the
benzodiazepines are less and less used
but they're still useful as a zhang jie
lititz so this is really quite
dispiriting especially because in the
1940s and 1950s as lithium the
antipsychotics and antidepressants sort
of appeared out of the good observations
of humans responding in unexpected ways
to compounds that were given there was a
sense that this would just keep rolling
and that psychiatry would be able to
climb out of the psychoanalytic pit in
which it found itself and have this
whole generation of effective
therapeutics not so in fact in that
really only about five or seven years
ago the European regulators the EMA
basically said you know what every time
there's a new antidepressant it's
heavily marketed and it costs European
governments several billion dollars and
you know what you haven't advanced
efficacy you know in more than half a
century and so we're not I don't know
that this was the right policy decision
but they basically said we're not going
to even approve another antidepressant
unless you can show greater efficacy or
you have a companion biomarker so at
least we know who might
bond and of course we don't know how to
do that that's pretty embarrassing but
that began or accelerated an exit of
industry out of this this field
something that by the way motivates us
at the Stanley Center and I hope
motivates this community because we have
to sort of get this therapeutics ball
rolling again and basically if you you
know I know there are some people from
in the audience I've ray you know from
local pharmaceutical companies and of
course if you all work on CNS but if you
ask management you know how do you want
to spend your marginal dollar do you
want to spend it on cancer where there's
you know hot and cold running targets
and by the way the pricing is out of
this world or do you want to risk you
know the 40th you know antipsychotic
drug it's quite clear that how they've
made their decision and and what they
say it's hard to argue is there's a
dearth of new molecular target and the
human brain and this is one of the key
problems again for this community to
worry about is inaccessible in life
right i mean imaging is absolutely
wonderful it's amazing to be able to
peer into the living human brain
structurally functionally but but that's
very different from being able to get
tissue in in the living brain so cancer
biologists you know wait outside the o.r
and the surgeon does a excisional biopsy
and routinely hands the scientists the
cells the disease we we can't do that
this is a skull from a Inca trepanation
they used to let evil spirits out this
is considered impolite I arbys will not
allow this intervention but as silly as
that sounds you know it wouldn't even
help all that much because our diseases
are not sell autonomous as cancer is are
as Bob already alluded to our these
diseases in the end require cell cell
connection
and complex circuits so this would say
that what we really need that are good
animal models of diseases but the
problem is in the last few years after
relying on really drug assays I'll come
back to this just in a second there's a
real disillusionment with the animal
models that that we have or at least
some of the typical ones which is not to
say i think some people are throwing the
baby out with the bathwater we're not
going to do without animal models but
except for some rare monogenic forms of
autism where we can at least you know
put penetrant genes into a mouse or
other organisms genome we really don't
even know how to go about modeling say
you know depression or where we
basically have no jeans or even
schizophrenia or you have lots of genes
but they're all of low penetrance as
you'll hear and there are no biomarkers
for clinical trials and again I've heard
heads of discoveries at pharmaceutical
companies basically say well look we
have to conduct these very very large
clinical trials we get these tiny effect
sizes if we're lucky because we don't
know ahead of time who is really a good
candidate for this therapeutic so we
have a pretty you know pretty tough
assignment here and you know we I think
I I've asked a lot I asked you know even
even back in the late 90s when I was in
ni-mh you know what has gone wrong and
you know in some sense these these
serendipities that launched the era of
modern psychopharmacology were a clear
clinical blessing but they became sort
of an intellectual curse which doesn't
mean we necessarily would have done
better focusing elsewhere but we allowed
the mechanisms of the existing drugs to
really rivet our attention on a very
small amount of brain function so in
terms of serendipity so this is
Alexander Fleming and everybody knows
the story right he was left his his
petri dishes out and they got moldy
and instead of throwing them out he saw
the rings of clearing of the bacterial
lawns and realized there might be an
inhibitory substance which turned out to
be penicillin and here is all real Ibori
a french surgeon and i suppose they all
do look like this dress like this he he
was interested in antihistamines as I
said Rome khulankor French drug company
was working on them and they gave him
this compound Thorazine which you know
nobody knew about d2 dopamine receptors
in 1951 but you know it had this
property and he gave it to his patients
as a pre anesthetic he was really
impressed with its sedating properties
he called up his buddies delay and den
occur at the psychiatric hospital he
said why don't you try this on some of
your agitation psychotic patients and
they did and lo and behold the sedation
turned out to be a side effect that they
develop tolerance to but what was
amazing is that over a few weeks
hallucinations and delusions started to
melt away and and core promazine this
also tells you that regulators were
different than was approved in the
United States to treat schizophrenia in
1954 right now it would still be in
toxicity testing probably but you know
la bory and his followers got stuck and
Fleming didn't so what was the
difference well the difference is that
in microbiology one could begin really
immediately to vary what was on the
petri dish you could find other soil
bacteria streptomyces other molds
different bacteria on your lawn and
pretty soon you can also begin a much
more reductionist biochemical and
ultimately later genetic analysis of
these microbes and and and and use this
sort of kind of thinking to discover new
antibiotics now you know in psychiatry
we couldn't couldn't do this again the
brain was inaccessible we didn't have
this kind of reductive biology but what
happened was people said well look what
are the
drugs do what do they do to an animal on
are there other compounds that will do
the same thing to an animal for
antipsychotic drugs the first test
really were based on the parkinsonian
side effects you get by blocking
dopamine d2 receptors so animals would
fall off a rotarod later we haven't rind
a pharmacologic tautology you inject
amphetamine which releases dopamine the
animals run around you screen a drug it
blocks dopamine d2 receptors and lo and
behold maybe you have a new
antipsychotic drug because you have a d2
blocker or dopamine blocker that crosses
the blood-brain barrier now the people
who came out up with these kinds of
tests weren't dumb they basically
worried always that this could be just a
way of rediscovering the same mechanism
again and again but it could have been a
way to discover truly maybe this really
was a way of modeling antipsychotic
drugs in general or in the case of
antidepressants putting a rodent in a
beaker of cold water and the rodent will
struggle and then it will float and if
you give it a imipramine the index
compound or drugs like imipramine it
will struggle for longer and then a
terrible thing happened behavioral
pharmacologist call this floating which
is probably wisdom right why hydrolyze
more ATP while waiting for this idiot to
pull me out of the beaker you know it
became floating became behavioral
despair right this anthropomorphic term
by which people deceived themselves
serious people I mean right so we got
into this you know self-fulfilling
prophecy even came up with this idea of
predictive validity that is if F an
animal you know ass apron II drug maybe
that validates it in in some way and
then this worse concept of faithful
editing so if this reminds me of what a
depressed person would do I don't know
you know then it's a model of depression
so we we bet we were stuck for decades
literally for decades
and but at the same time so now we get
to the more optimistic bit although it
stays hard at the same time it was
always known that there had to be
molecular Clues lying around in our
genomes because these disorders are
among the most heritable of all
relatively common disorders so on this
side this is a nice piece of work from
irv goddess minh that shows basically
that the more DNA you share with
somebody who has schizophrenia the
greater your risk of having
schizophrenia so monozygotic twin if you
have a monozygotic twin with
schizophrenia you have a 50-percent risk
the the population base rate is
something just under one percent you
know if you have a dizygotic twin it's a
15-percent another first-degree relative
ten to thirteen percent it's interesting
these suggest that there may be some
environmental effects I'm have been
genetically more DNA you share the
greater your risk and the heritability
is based on twin methods for autism or
in the point 65 2.8 range for
schizophrenia point eight for bipolar
disorder just slightly less so so genes
have a lot to say they're not fate right
here are the monozygotic coach winds
have only a 50-percent concordance
although the unaffected co-twin we now
know has a thinner cerebral cortex then
then more distant relatives and has some
cognitive impairment but doesn't have
schizophrenia doesn't have psych poses
so genes are not fate but they're very
very influential but we couldn't find
them so again just you know
autobiographically when I was ni-mh
director people were doing looking in
families that seem to have very high
density of schizophrenia or bipolar
disorder and what they thought was that
a highly penetrant gene that would be
discoverable with the methods of a day
must be segregating in these families
and this turned out not to be right and
we'll come back to that in in just a bit
but
you know you can understand the field
but really was desperate for some
molecular clues and and and this method
went on and on beyond its potential
utility in fact one one of the things i
did i had this committee looking at
genetic studies at ni-mh and we knew we
needed sample side i actually had this
guy Eric Lander this was 1998 as a
member of the committee and you know
little did I know but that we would
start a lifelong relationship but but
one of the things we tried to do to get
people to actually share their results
in their data to try to increase the
power but in those days you know people
would rather share a toothbrush than
their data because they all thought just
you know with with just one more family
they would would get it so that didn't
really work so I basically started
paying for these linkage analyses as a
way of banking DNA for the future and it
was a great idea and we banked many
hundreds of DNA samples except that it
was pathetically small as it turned out
it turned out to be just a drop in the
bucket but nonetheless these these
studies didn't give us durable findings
because the the genetic architecture of
these diseases is incredibly complex and
to cut to the chase most of you know
this you know many hundreds of genes
maybe over a thousand are involved in
different people in different families
in creating the risk of autism and an
overlapping set for schizophrenia and a
different overlapping set for bipolar
disorder and maybe hundreds of genes
maybe more maybe five percent of our
genomes for each illness and within
those jeans there may be thousands of
different variants different alleles so
the the idea that you could solve these
needles in a haystack looking in ten
families with six affected or eight
affected people you know
statistically impossible but nobody knew
that so we were waiting for technology
and again autobiographically you know I
done as Bob said I'd done very basic
molecular neuroscience but having been
ni-mh director and having been exposed
to the suffering and the disability I
really wanted to do something
translational and I was an absolute
despair of doing it so I took a what was
planned to be a five year time out
turned out to be a ten-year time out at
Harvard and while I was in the timeout
box an amazing thing happened we got
advances in genomic technology where the
cost of sequencing DNA came down
approximately a million fold we got the
ability to make human embryonic stem
cells and then IPS cells we got the
ability to engineer them with relative
ease first with zinc fingers and then
talons and then is everyone in this
community knows fun wherever you are you
know with crisper and and now son of
crisper and then daughter of crisp you
know I mean and and and so we can begin
to shuttle genes in and out of organisms
and fills and all kinds of technologies
for systems neurobiology so all of a
sudden it becomes possible to stop
play-acting at science and do science
but it's really hard and we all you know
again I hope lots of people here are in
this together so for ancient common
variants you know there are now gene
chips they have about a million snips on
them but you know a million snips even
though they're there they're more maybe
10 million common snips in the genome
mark haplotypes you know blocks of DNA
that tend to segregate together and we
can get a pretty good idea of low sigh
and the genome associated with risk and
now there's a psych chip ben neal at the
Stanley Center was the key architect
there was a community effort that gives
you a good gos array and a rare variant
array but also people got to nominate
something like the 50
thousand favorite lo sai including copy
number variants and Volvo psychiatric
disorders and already people are
thinking about the second version but
right now for 70 bucks you can do you
know a chip on somebody and that that
includes you know i'm a former provo so
that includes overhead and you know
fringe benefits for the machines for the
robots this is amazing what you can
study an awful lot of people now one
thing happened in human population
history which is that we percolated
along in these ancient populations with
a you know few tens of millions of
humans and then we had the Neolithic
Revolution learned how to farm and then
we have the Industrial Revolution and
then we have McDonald's going the other
way but human populations expanded from
literally let's say at the time of the
Industrial Revolution maybe a quarter of
a billion people to about eight billion
people today in 10 or 12 generations so
no time for cleansing natural selection
about 60 new mutations per you know new
human being and so there is this
staggering number of rare and ultra rare
and private variants that one couldn't
possibly array on a chip so we have the
sequence but again with the cost of
sequencing coming down this now becomes
feasible now common variant analysis I
think most of you know this involves
finding that a snip in an adequately
powered sample is more associated with
schizophrenia than with unaffected
individuals at the most imp lista clev
ille so this is a Manhattan plot of this
is from more than a year ago there's
actually more information now these are
the chromosomes rate at the bottom from
one on down this is the the minus log 10
probability and this red line which is
sort of you know sort of the I think
mark daily kind of invented this but
it's basically p less than equal to 0
point 05 corrected for million
comparisons and this is sort of like the
threshold that the community accept that
something is durable that it's not going
to go away and you can publish it but
with 37,000 cases of schizophrenia and
130,000 controls there were a hundred
and eight you know independent low sighs
so these are not individual causative
variants but you know chunk reasonably
sized chunks of DNA that increase the
risk of schizophrenia but you know about
a third of them clearly pick out a
single gene which is good and about
another third maybe is two or three
genes and some of them have you
scratching your head but what's really
important here is the average odds ratio
if you have one of these risk variants
is only one point oh eight so each one
increases risk by only eight percent so
we have to bear this in mind as we do
biology right that this is going to be
pretty challenging now just to sort of
illustrate the the issue with these low
side the first thing is that as I've
said they're chunks of DNA so they have
to be fine mapped if you want to find
the causative variant the second thing
across all of these genome-wide
Association studies across all of
biology about ninety percent of the
variants are in regulatory regions and
that's challenging because we frankly
it's a lot easier to think of biological
experiments to do with coding variants
then with regulatory variants I mean
some regulatory regions are really well
understood but many aren't but also this
kind of illustrates the the again what
if you think about how we're going to
interrogate the function of these low
sigh so this is this is just a cartoon
of
an l-type calcium channel and one flavor
has a an alpha one subunit encoded by
the gene kak nuh 1c and there is a rare
highly penetrant gain-of-function
mutation that causes something called
timothy syndrome which is a very severe
illness with autistic features
intellectual disability seizures facial
discs morphology and it can be lethal
it's an l channel won't surprise you
there there can be cardiac arrhythmias
this is the variant in the very same
gene associated with schizophrenia
bipolar disorder both and this is in a
putative Lee in an enhancer within an
intron and there's still not full
agreement as to what this in what the
risk variant does compared to the non
risk variant but it's thought that it's
a modest loss of function maybe it
decreases expression by ten percent in a
subset of neurons in the brain and other
cells that happen to utilize certain
transcription factors so you get the the
difference between you know rare
penetrant near Mendelian disease and
what we're dealing with in in
schizophrenia but multiplied maybe by a
thousand well rare protein altering
alleles so alleles in protein coding
regions are more neurobiological e
actionable and for all of us right just
easier experiments to do and the idea
was to fence these are recent a lot of
them might be more penetrant and they're
too designed so the first design that is
generally used it is something called
the trio study to healthy parents and an
affected offspring it's been studied
most in autism and schizophrenia and
these are really in many ways different
illnesses because in autism a certain
percentage
five percent less than ten percent have
sort of rare Mendelian forms some of
which are due to de novo that is in the
in the offspring single base changes
that cause a recognizable change in the
gene usually early truncation of the
gene so you get a non functional gene
and basically haploinsufficiency that
that's a bit of bit carelessly used
there but but I think it cared and and
and across many sites including one here
that ben neal was the was the first
author on but also you know matt stayed
and ever Eichler in a group at Cold
Spring Harbor people coalesced on a
certain number of genes Kaitlin sumo ha
and Mark Daly's group has a very nice
model showing that these are genes that
are constrained in evolution that if
they have fewer mutations far fewer
mutations then you would expect based on
a nucleic acid sequence and if you get a
truncating mutation in one of these you
know bad things happen and in some ways
they are not so dissimilar to some of
the monogenic disorders of mark bears
here's works on fragile x and on maybe
ret but these really are the minority
and people are going to do excellent
biology on these but we'll come back to
the again the challenge for the human
and I think everybody is is struggling
with that for schizophrenia this
strategy has not paid off it doesn't
look like there are there's a big signal
um and maybe autism begins so early in
life these damaging developmental
mutations you know have a chance to act
schizophrenia has onset late teens early
20s or are some rare childhood on sets
but we're not seeing a lot of these
really damaging de Novo's the other
strategy to get to actionable
neurobiology looking at protein altering
variants is simply case control
and again this is made possible by the
ability to sequence right now it's
really what the we're mostly sequencing
whole exomes all the protein coding
genes cost about 300 bucks whole genomes
are you know we're beginning to sequence
whole genomes I'll talk about that in a
bit but you know this is the this is one
to two percent of the genome the data
generation from whole genomes is
enormous it is challenging to handle
probably the only way to deal with it is
to have everything in the cloud and
compute in the cloud and if you want
your primary data will send it to you in
a moving truck with tapes because there
isn't the bandwidth to download it but
even more important that it's kind of so
but the most important thing is we don't
really know how to interpret a lot of
what goes on in whole genomes I suppose
they'll be regions where there's a jiwa
signal you know in what looks like a
gene desert and that will focus our
attention will learn over time but right
now whole exomes are just much more
efficient and again one thinks one knows
what kinds of experiments won't my to
the problem is I told you this parable
about human the expansion of human
population since the Neolithic
Revolution because there's it what it
tells you there's an enormously high
background rate of variation now some of
its associated with other illnesses but
a lot of its just neutral variation even
if it changes the protein sequence right
you know might change one amino acid to
another in a way that is not
particularly harmful it might be in some
you know carboxy tail somewhere waving
in the breeze not hurting anything and
the other thing is I think everybody's
disappointment everybody I know actually
thinks they predicted this but I didn't
that you know we're not seeing highly
penetrant alleles among these rare and
ultra rare variants for the most part so
there's been a whole exome sequencing of
6,000 people with schizophrenia say from
Sweden and no single gene is
statistically significant now people go
to great Lane
two papers in nature can't complain but
ah but the way to get significance out
of this is to overlay the data with very
Theory Laden gene clustering some of
which really makes no sense at all I
mean look people you know it's it's
exciting to do but you know one of the
gene clusters was is associated with the
marker is is arc which is a protein
which is induced by neural activity and
if you look at that as a cluster you can
think you find significance of trouble
is the art cluster is co-regulated it's
not all in the same cell it's not in the
same complex so i would say lets you
know as much as we were in a hurry let's
back off and see if we can actually
determine whether any of these
gazillions of protein altering variants
really matter for the disease and the
reason to say that is as most people
this room know once you start doing a
biology experiment then then you're
really in deep right then you have you
know reagents and people and a
commitment and i wouldn't want to be
responsible from sending you on a
wild-goose chase I'd really you know
want to have some sense that that that
this variant is telling us a story so
what are we going to do well we were
kind of VAS as you'll see in a minute
we're going to vastly increase the
sample size try to get more power we
could focus on those genes that have
rare protein altering variants that we
already know are significant by G wasps
and there's a great story already I'll
just touch on in a minute that Jen pan
is working on here we could focus on
interpretable categories like the loss
of functions which you see in in autism
but that's not going to get us very far
in terms of common forms of autism
schizophrenia bipolar ADHD in the light
we can very very carefully use
complementary insights from biology some
some variants may be so rare that we're
going to run out of humans before we get
a p-value and if we're going to put
together a biological story you know
it's so easy to fool yourself because
you come at it with your priors but
maybe you know that you see the
directionality of something from a G
wasthat is genome-wide significant you
know for common variants you can achieve
statistical power and look at an allelic
series and see if they converge but we
really have to be very skeptical when we
do that but I think it's good it's it's
it's beyond question we're just not
though we're just not going to have
enough samples ultimately to get the
kind of statistical significance by
itself that can assure you that when you
do biology you're working on something
we know is involved in autism or
schizophrenia one thing I've been
thinking about I haven't convinced it's
too early but using you know stem cell
technology and crisper cast nine or in
animals can we create sort of sensitized
screens you know the way people do in
drosophila in different ways couldn't we
can we take stem cells that come from
patients and make them neurons and
actually remove some you know correct or
rescue some some risk alleles and and
and create a cell system in which we
might then in adding testing new alleles
of interest we might see in effect can
we begin to human eyes slightly humanize
the marmosets that are now living
somewhere happily at MIT again to create
we don't know barely enough we've just I
don't think we've quite assembled our
whole genome sequence yet but you know
can we overtime humanize enough gene so
that we again have a somewhat sensitized
screen to
at these low penetrance alleles because
again these alleles you know to make the
point that explicit that's been implicit
44 we all have risk alleles right we all
have for every every common disease and
lots of people who have the disease
don't have the one you're interested in
its really the pile up of these plus you
know bad luck right you can't wire up a
hundred trillion synapses
deterministically plus some
environmental interaction which we don't
yet fully understand so so so maybe we
can create genetically sensitized
screens to begin to understand what some
of the other genes are telling us and
then a really critical principle the
reason that we want to find you know
lots and lots of these genes and not say
oh we've got to to work on we should
just do that and I will come back is
because I think we're going to learn
something from convergence and I'm going
to come back to that now mark daily and
ben neal took some analyses are already
in the literature and use those to sort
out the fact that we shouldn't actually
hold our breath waiting for highly
penetrant alleles so in a number of
scandinavian countries studies of
fecundity have been done and so let me
just yeah i know this is really hard to
read but if you're a male with
schizophrenia and you are compared with
your unaffected sibling males you will
have about a quarter as many children
females have a little bit more about
fifty percent female tenth of a later on
set with schizophrenia and and a
somewhat milder course but still it's a
severe reduction for a male with autism
the again you have about a quarter as
many children as your sim so in modeling
this what Mark and Ben and their
colleagues have shown pretty
convincingly is that any allele that
increases the risk by more than ten
percent that is 1.1 fold is quickly
washed out of the population evolution
is very much at work
right these disorders confer a severe
reproductive disadvantage and it's the
same the reason that the de novo
strategy is so critical in autism is a
lot of these just are not transmitted
these kids often travel you know with
autism and you know very severe
intellectual disability are not going to
transmit those alleles so that's a
situation right we're going to discover
lots and lots of these but they're going
to have low penetrance and the ones that
are protein altering are going to be
sometimes so rare that we're not going
to necessarily have a p-value I thought
I said this was going to get more
optimistic but we'll get there okay so
this is the way I think many of us not
all of us but many of us in the Stanley
Center are thinking about these problems
and of course there's a lot of room for
argument so the first thing is don't
Mendel eyes don't see your favorite gene
and say you know that's it you know that
right because these jeans you know work
only in certain genetic backgrounds so
forth because these are genes of small
effect I'm going to you know we we have
to assume that that they act by
converging on a much smaller number of
pathways and molecular machines than
there are genetic variants out there if
the biology doesn't work that way then
it's hard to explain the as
heterogeneous as the diseases are the
relatively stereotypic age of onset and
symptoms we have to respect the cellular
diversity of the brain you know in if
you work on liver you're in luck you
know you've got about three cell types
pata sites and kupffer cells and
endothelial and a few wandering
lymphocytes but in the brain you know
obviously a cell type is so important if
only recognizing
neurons and the different kinds of glia
excitatory and inhibitory neurons but we
all know that there are vast differences
even among these subclasses in fact in
the current brain project we're going to
find out maybe at least some
approximation how many different cell
types there are but the point is we're
going to need a lot of single cell
analysis again remember a lot of the
common variants are regulatory so
they're not going to be acting in every
in every cell I think we've learned that
we have to respect evolution in the
selection of models and we have to ask
you know am I asking a question that can
be answered in this organism right as
we're interrogating the jeans and at the
same time we have to recognize that we
you know we say we're working on
schizophrenia we're working on bipolar
disorder there's no such thing right I
mean these diagnoses were designed to be
categories picking out narrow cylinders
of human psychopathology you know
through August consultative processes
like you know I would say two
psychiatrists have a doughnut and decide
on the criteria you know these are you
know very heterogeneous but but they're
really spectra they are not
discontinuous from health something that
at least Robinson has been showing very
clearly for autism that you know people
with diagnosable autism people who are
considered affected just have a bigger
pile up of risk genes then then then
people who are considered unaffected but
these genes have similar effects that
just their effect gets attenuated as you
have fewer and fewer and yes of course
genes by themselves or not not fate so
one of the things we're going to have to
do since we know we're not able to ask
people lots of questions and really know
what's wrong with them is we probably
have to have to get a lot of genotypes
and begin to have cohorts where we can
recall people by genotype and then
really phenotype them again with new
biological hypothesis
okay now people ask why do you guys care
about alleles of small effect so one
answer is that's all there is right not
a lot of choice but I think what's
really important is to remember and this
this really goes for the g wasps where
we really get statistical certainty is
it if you are confident about a locus
that locus if you find map it implicates
a particular gene and if you think about
the convergence on molecular machines
you know look if you if a gene if it's
not implicated but if cam kinase two
were a risk allele it might be for some
diseases it's in every cell in the body
but you begin to figure out what it
might be doing if it's in you know a
cell where you know an nmda receptor
subunit or an amp receptor subunit is
also implicated so you get this sort of
convergent hughes so gene so alleles
identified genes genes identify pathways
protein networks biological processes
and cell types right where they were
they pile up and so those are those are
really critical cues clues and also the
what's what the allele does tells you
the directionality so you know a loss of
function in in some protein tells you
maybe your drug is gonna have to
slightly increase activity so there's a
lot of information even though these are
alleles of small effect and I would
remind you you know stat you know for
statins the jiwa signal in the target of
statins hmg-coa reductase increases risk
independently by 2% so it's just that in
the pathway it's the rate limiting
enzyme for cholesterol biosynthesis so
you put the genetic clues together with
biology okay so we the hypothesis this
nice picture that Casper Lodge gave me
that that the hypothesis is that the
combinatorial information will place
these genes into disease relevant
pathways so what
I've told you with this you know almost
perseverating my frontal lobes are okay
on convergence we have a long way to go
so this is what we want to do in the
Stanley Center in terms of the genetics
and and what's critical is to say it
this way you know we'd like to genotype
and sequence disorders of high
heritability with really dramatic enough
phenotypes that we're not totally
reliant on the DSM that are not the most
heterogeneous Oh schizophrenia bipolar
autism ADHD all highly heritable and and
we want to analyze them to diminishing
returns which will I think we'll know
diminishing returns when we see it but
even for schizophrenia were very much on
the steep part of the gene discovery
curve where there's no slowing down in
gene discovery so now in schizophrenia
you know autism is lagging and bipolar
is lagging behind that but we'll catch
up this year there are 60,000 cases that
have been G wasps they're actually
something more than 130 independent low
sign known that you know I showed you
the slide from the last publication six
thousand exome sequence two thousand
genomes and by 2018-19 we hope to have
more than a hundred thousand cases gos
40,000 exome sequences borrowing from
the you know the military metaphor of
the Bush era we call it the surge and
maybe 10 cases of whole genomes the
other thing is we've been using
population samples of convenience these
wonderful European you know bio banks
and population registries and these well
organized health systems but that's just
a tiny sliver of human genetic diversity
and if we're really going to do this we
need to sample all of human genetic
diversity partly to find interesting
rare variants partly there'll be
different allele frequencies importantly
if these diseases stratified really for
global equity right we you know we have
to assume that these chronic
non-communicable diseases will stratify
and so you can see we're beginning you
know new waves this is still Europe of
course although Finland has some
interesting population isolates but in
Japan in China we're going to collect
more than 30,000 new samples and that
could potentially expand Shanghai is 30
million people it's bigger than most
European countries and there's one big
psychiatric hospital that sort of
through affiliates can ascertain most of
the cases we're starting in Mexico
looking at the admixture or really
interested obviously the Native American
population and we feel we really have to
collect in sub-saharan Africa we know
that this going to be difficult we are
trying to work with some British
charities Harrison Conan is leaving
leading us to create training programs
for investigators we don't want to do
Safari research you know you give us
your samples we may remember to send you
the paper I mean we can't win that's
clearly terribly wrong we know it's
going to be hard but again from a global
equity point of view but also human
genetic diversity is greater in Africa
by far than anywhere else in the world
so that's the genetics clearly I said we
have to respect the cell diversity of
the brain I'm going to go pretty quickly
now you know mate perhaps at Evan macaws
co and steeper Carol's lab working with
Aviv Regev developed a not very nice
high-throughput single-cell RNA seek
procedure called drop seat which allows
you to you know isolate cells from the
brain still problematic that you know
you amputate processes you know there's
more work to be done here suspend them
in droplets prime your RNA synthesis
with a bar-coded bead and then you can
massively parallel do RNA seek but for
therapeutics you actually need to know
what these molecular machines are these
proteomic interact ohms and single cell
proteomics is not not any time soon that
I know of so we're doing single cell
type protein
mix where kevin egan and Lynda Barrett
are growing you know industrial
quantities of I pretty identical getting
pretty good at this you know in this
case excitatory pyramidal neurons we
still have to you know get other neural
types inhibitory interneurons and people
helping with that are both collaborators
from the outside may be gored for shells
early paola are a lot of here and and
and basically do interaction proteomics
in these cells and then check our work
and it's very iterative ugly process
against human postmortem brain maybe
some animal brain but to try to get a
sense of you know what what these what
these these machines are that are
affected by risk alleles okay now you
can get lucky with a lot of hard work so
in schizophrenia so this is the famous
post-mortem study from david lewis's lab
very small number of brains but we do
hope it's true in textbooks must be true
you can see the the dendrites and you
can see these very healthy-looking cells
and then what you see is in the to
schizophrenia cases especially this one
there's clearly a loss of components and
of synapses along the way that have some
people suggested excessive synaptic
pruning and
and along with this i should say with
this thinning comes cognitive deficits
so one of the things that you know was
discovered where maybe we're taking a
leap maybe jenn pan is taking a leap one
of the risk alleles is kacta one I it's
a calcium channel subunit that that is
encodes the Alpha subunit of see AV 3.3
expressed throughout the brain highly
expressed in the thalamic reticular
nucleus and lo and behold the TRN is
entirely gabaergic it controls sleep
spindles and Dara manoa who's here has
established with Bob stickle that not
only is that that that sleep spindle
activity is decreased in people with
schizophrenia and it's really
interesting because sleep spindles
probably represent some large calcium
influx that might have to do with memory
consolidation which also may have to do
with stage two sleep when you generate
sleep spindles so this this g was
finding has pointed us toward you know
this cell group now again you know we
need to compounds to modulate this
calcium channel but this may not be a
therapeutic target to help memory
consolidation and cognition in
schizophrenia maybe maybe calcium
channel agonist will never turn out to
be a good idea because of cardiac
problems but you know if we can study at
the single-cell level TRN cells which r
opinion colleagues are doing maybe we'll
find other potential targets clues to
biology but this is the way that you
know that these these variants help us
and in the case of pruning per se now
this isn't published yet but i know that
both steve mccarroll and best stephens
have spoken about this including at our
symposium just two weeks ago but
basically the biggest association peak
ofrenda is in the MHC locus turned out
not to be an HLA they're actually three
signals but but the biggest signal is
with complement factor c4 and Beth
Stevens had shown previously that that
complement factors are the eat me signal
that synapses display in synaptic
pruning and you know you can see wild
type c 4 plus minus heterozygote c 4
minus minus you can see that there's
more pruning in the wild type and less
pruning when your knockout c4 and humans
with schizophrenia have higher levels of
c-4 so again this is a kind of thing
that you know maybe especially given the
picture I showed you from the David
Lewis lab and the scans maybe
schizophrenia is a partly a disease of
over pruning where you know a lot of
synaptic genes are involved but during
synaptic pruning and adolescents they
don't smell right to the microglia or
they attract too much complement what it
it gives us a toehold but the problem of
course is that just it's like it you
know what are we going to so get a
module eight synaptic pruning well under
pruning is not so good either so all
these things have sort of a inverted
u-shaped dose-response curve so if we're
going to help the people in the Stanley
Center who are working on therapeutics
which includes it Skolnick you know to
capitalize on this we'd better have some
real biomarkers for synaptic pruning so
we're collaborating around the world
including Australia where there's a very
good schizophrenia prodrome study trying
to get serial CSF measures to look for
compliments metabolites of course will
do unbiased proteomics at the same time
because who's going to let you give a
drug to a you know relatively healthy
fifteen-year-old clearly getting into
trouble that will modulate pruning
unless you have something more than just
cognitive testing right we need we need
some biomarkers so this is a this effort
to get to therapeutics which begins in
genetic
because psychiatry has been so without
these Clues is going to take a long time
so I'm going to end with the hard hard
problem which is how to model these
disorders you know how do you know how
are we going to understand what these
genes are doing you again we've had some
nice examples where we get pointed at
the TRN we get pointed it at pruning but
for a lot of these genes we don't know
what sells in bipolar disorder if you
ask me what cells in the brain are
involved in bipolar disorder I couldn't
begin to I don't have a clue right so
we're clearly going to need animal
models cellular models and you know
might obviously give us access to
remarkable technologies like like opto
genetics but the problem of course is
that these are relatively low throughput
but the lack of penetrant alleles really
you know makes it very very challenging
because you're not going to see a
phenotype with one or ten and how did
you choose which 10 and if you're not
the G now that's not going to tell you
you know imagine knocking at the l-type
calcium channel might have side effects
like death but it won't tell you what's
happening in 23 neural subtypes where
it's the promoter you know that is
slightly down regulated and and so what
we call so low penetrance really means
that the genetic background matters the
other genes and environment but the
other genes really matter so how we
going to get there well the most
important thing is and I love this quote
from dubs Anthony nothing in biology
makes sense except in light of evolution
so we we always have to ask if we if we
want to disease model it's not like
basic science where we can you know
choose any anything we've like as long
as it gives generalizable results we're
going to intervene in something we have
to say you know not just does this
organism have you know conditioned fear
the way humans have conditioned for your
butt
does a molecular target we're interested
in is that conserved and are the cells
and the circuits conserved all the way
to humans some things housekeeping genes
protein chaperones are conserved in
yeast and then we should use yeast it's
a lot easier but again it really depends
on the question you're asking and we
haven't really been doing this
effectively as a community and I think
again this idea of matching models to
questions and I would illustrate this so
here's k sitting in the front row works
on fear but uh but you know in fear
we've learned an incredible amount
because evolution has solved a lot of
the basic fear circuitry a lot of basic
reward circuitry very early on but are
these animals by themselves models of
human disease even if we increase you
know condition feared we have an anxiety
disorder model and the problem is that
in humans that the illness not doesn't
only have to do with the fear circuitry
but also with cognitive control exerted
by the prefrontal cortex and here are
there are enormous differences between
rodents and humans and so what it tells
us is we can learn an enormous amount in
the rodent model but then we have to
think again about how we're going to
incorporate the the cognitive control
aspects and some of this we may or may
not be able to do in rodents so again
this is why evolution is so important so
I am going to skip this and skip this so
in the end we want to we again we have
to reach out to the whole community to
figure out what models we can use but in
the end we really I think we have to
humanize a lot of our biology so you
know some of this has to do with IPS
cell some of this has to do with
organoids but I've also had already two
workshops at the Institute of Medicine
that's brought in regulators you know
FDA basically saying what if we can't
have an animal model what do we do that
and trying to get them to move to a
position where they are by the way for
cancer but not for CNS where as long as
you've done toxicity and you know
compound is safe
I'd like them to say that and we don't
have such compounds yet that we can test
them in human subjects because how are
we going to use you know a pourcel test
as an efficacy gate certainly no no
scientific director in pharma would
allow their CNS group to do that and and
and so I think we again as a community
we have this really tough problem of
figuring out how to take this trove of
genes and turn it into useful biological
information it's so much harder than
cancer research because of the
evolutionary recency and the
inviolability of the human brain but I
am optimistic I think we can think about
these things together and hopefully make
some really much needed progress and so
there are many many two people many many
more people than I can list or thank
individually I probably left lots of
important people off of these but I was
running out of room on the slide but
this really is a community effort and
hopefully more people in this community
can become involved in the effort thank
you very much